this video is sponsored by audible start
listening with the link in the
description there are some things Apple
just loves design aluminum excuse me
aluminum high grade aluminium solid slab
of aluminium and secrecy to keep a
surprise it hires former FBI agents
searches more bags than TSA and
disguises its products with fake
companies like IP application
development Ltd iPad but there are some
things even the world's most profitable
company can't hide this is a list of
companies acquired by Apple most make
perfect sense
authentic became touch ID Siri well
Siri but around 2014 you start to see a
pattern first a company creating tiny
super-bright high-density displays then
one specializing in eye tracking an
augmented reality headset and a couple
AR software startups plus a handful of
patents and job descriptions all
suggesting the same thing smart
augmented reality glasses directions the
weather really anything projected right
onto your vision the technology may not
seem ready we may not seem ready and
others have tried and failed all of
which could be said about the iPhone in
2007 of course acquisitions are just
acquisitions there are no guarantees and
Apple loves saying no it doesn't very
often release a new product but there's
good reason to think smart glasses are
coming Apple is the perfect company to
make them and now is the time to do it
[Music]
if you're at all skeptical well you
should be every other week we hear a new
version of the same Matloff blanc
technology is on the verge of radically
disrupting Blanc
industry watch out we're about to
reinvent wearable blockchains or
leverage proactive mesh networks and the
world will never be the same the few
experts who see where an industry is
really going get drowned out by a sea of
companies promoting their world-changing
idea which makes it pretty tough to
predict the future so when I say smart
glasses and you say I've heard this
before
well I can't really blame you but there
are still ways of separating a hero from
a zero the Gartner hype cycle explains
why new technology seems to come out of
nowhere and then disappear with no
explanation
progress is never a straight line but
it's also not random it tends to follow
a pattern first a very primitive
prototype gets some attention the media
desperate for cliques jumps right over
its flaws to its best-case scenario
10 15 years from now and not just in
tech a dietary study with a tiny sample
size became the headline why you must
eat chocolate daily that's what you and
I see so we're inevitably disappointed
when we get a glimpse of reality then
while we've mostly forgotten about it
real progress is made this is where our
slash futurology claims it can cure
cancer this is where you add blockchain
to the name of your ice tea company
boosting its stock 200% and this is when
we're told it's coming in three to five
years every three to five years some
technologies die trying to get attention
some are only hype virtual reality is
somewhere around here far enough we know
it's viable for games and entertainment
but while it steals our attention
augmented reality quietly moves forward
sure it's earlier and more uncertain but
its potential is much much bigger and
Apple seems to agree it's been a huge
focus of the company since iOS 11 Tim
Cook even compared his promise to the
smartphone I mean listen to Heather
website describes it imagine if the line
between the virtual and the real simply
didn't exist
your classroom could become the cosmos
the past could be as vivid as the
present and this is just the beginning
welcome to a new world that's pretty
bold for what's currently just a few
games and the ability to sample IKEA
furniture
what kind of dining set defines me as a
person of course all of this is brand
new but even if there are really great
apps in a year or two there's one huge
problem for it to work you constantly
have to hold up your phone or dare I say
13-inch iPad it's just awkward AR is
kind of the new drone incredibly hyped
and sure it's fun for a minute or two
but only practical for a few specific
applications
unless Apple knows this why invest so
much time and money because they know
what we don't this is just an
intermediary between today's phones and
tomorrow's glasses it's a very clever
solution to a fake problem if Apple
wants to keep its glasses secret it
can't tell developers and apps won't be
ready when it launches but what if they
could have their cake and eat it too
that's a our kit developers can start
working now without knowing what's
coming meanwhile Apple collects feedback
and improves the technology by the time
glasses arrive they'll have already
proven their value directions projected
right onto the street translation of the
world around you context for your day
and so on plus I mean the product names
itself eyesight iPod iPhone eyeglasses
eyewear come on
except none of this is exclusive to
Apple in fact some company called Google
kinda already tried this why would Apple
be any more successful
[Music]
apple is rarely the first to do
something and glasses would be no
exception Microsoft introduced the
hololens in 2015 there's a the magic
leap and intel vond snapchat spectacles
sold from a vending machine
somehow uglier than the app itself and
the view get it because view rhymes with
blue as in they really blew it naming
their company a pun okay look at their
website your glasses will be able to do
more than meets the eye I see this is
not a business it's just an excuse to
make puns what a sorry sight but most
interesting is Google glass and the
million reasons why it failed like to do
anything you tilt your head 30 degrees
and speak okay glass discreetly take a
photo or use a touchpad on the side of
your head both equally terrible it was
expensive poorly marketed and lacked a
compelling feature but most of all it
just looks well let's say there's room
for improvement the challenge of all of
these is just as much design as
technology like I think this joke writes
itself but if there's any company that
can turn a tool you have to wear into an
accessory you want to its Apple glass
spent years being developed in public
but glasses should be released for quick
mass adoption and acceptance something
Apple might know a thing or two about
they should also be demoed in person
giving apples 500 retail stores a huge
advantage over to say Microsoft's
hundred I even know the perfect year to
release it although we'll see hindsight
is you get it
but seriously isn't it just way too
early technology arrives in waves first
early adopters then the public
eventually even the Luddites but between
these is an invisible hole to see it we
have to remember the hype cycle here at
peak excitement it's very easy to get a
few users these are early adopters and
they give the illusion of momentum the
hole is the steep descent that follows
after the hype getting users is much
much harder it takes a lot of kinetic
and
for a product to pass this filter a
journalist will wear any piece of glass
with a camera taped to it but Apple
designs for the masses only what can
survive the gap which creates two
challenges for glasses first the
technology has to be really good the
watch proves they can make small
batteries last a whole day and design a
tiny but mighty system on a chip it
would need a bright high-density display
like micro LED which it's already
developing but then there's the camera
which brings us to the second challenge
the other kind of optics it has to be
well not creepy consumers will think
black mirror the circle wall-e and so on
even with apples focus on privacy these
are very real challenges and could delay
its release but glasses are more than a
new product they're a critical part of
Apple strategy moving in the direction
of more transparent more personal
technology because the smartphone won't
last forever the only way a company so
dependent on one product can survive is
to replace itself not wait for someone
else to it's a philosophy rooted in the
company by Steve Jobs and one reason I
recommend his official biography with
audible you can listen on your way to
school or work at the gym or whenever
else I started listening to audiobooks
in high school and it really changed my
habits
it turns the necessary but very boring
moments of your life into the ones you
look forward to I'm almost always
listening to at least one book and one
of my favorite things is reading about
the CEO of a company I like for the
grand theory of Apple Amazon and this
video I learned much of the content by
understanding the person behind the
company their personality what motivates
them and how they came to start their
business and because this author talked
for hours with Steve Jobs and the people
around him it has a lot of detail you
just won't find anywhere else
another is the everything store the
story of Jeff Bezos and Amazon I'm
convinced there's no human on earth like
Bezos his mindset is really interesting
to hear about and speaking of Amazon
Prime members can listen to audible for
only 495 a month for their first three
months you can pick any book they have a
month and if you don't like it and I
absolutely love this you just click
return and pick another go to
audible.com slash poly matter or text
poly matter to 500 500
again that's audible.com slash pol why
ma tter
or text pol why ma tter
to five zero zero five zero zero
[Music]